this is tomorrow reading for reviewer
richard wakeling like most detective
stories lost judgment begins with a
ghastly discovery of a maga infested
corpse a single homicide is merely the
tip of the iceberg of course but the
unusual circumstances surrounding the
dead bodies discovery set the stage for
another compelling mystery for private
investigator takayuki yagami to solve
his latest adventure still dips its feet
into the deep end of the criminal
underworld but lost judgment distances
itself from its yakuza flavoured origins
with much more regularity than its
predecessor resulting in a better more
distinct game that still tinged with an
over sense of deja vu
[Music]
this begins right from the off as the
first hour or so was spent traversing
the well-worn streets of kamurocho
revisiting the bustling red light
district for the umpteenth time still
doesn't grow still thanks to its lively
atmosphere and intricate visual design
it's a place full of fond memories and
there's a pleasant sense of comfort in
its familiarity yet it's hard not to
feel relieved when yagami's latest case
takes you south of tokyo and to the port
city of yokohama the fictional district
of isezaki ijinsho was first introduced
in last year's yakuza like a dragon and
makes its return in lost judgment
relatively untouched it's a bigger urban
sprawl than kaimurocho but still
maintains the same density step through
the automatic doors of a pop-up store
and you'll be greeted by a short
electronic tune that announces your
arrival the magazine aisle is stacked
with lifestyle magazines manga and
cookbooks while the refrigerators at the
back of the store are filled with
assorted snacks elsewhere you can head
to the bar district to find each cozy
hangout stocked with real world alcohol
while passing beneath the pai fang in
chinatown will lead you to restaurants
adorned with dragons and golden guardian
lions there are club sega arcades where
you can play the likes of virtua fighter
5 final showdown space harrier and even
the ill-advised sonic fighting game
sonic the fighters
if none of these tickle your fancy
there's another sequel to the pseudo
house of the dead sequel introduced in
judgement this time is called hammer of
the dead a fully fledged light gun
shooter that sees zombies invade the
streets
outside of the hypnotic lights of the
arcade you can also play shogi and
mahjong battled against ai opponents in
a mario party svr board game compete in
drone races hit home runs at the batting
cages or simply befriend the
neighborhood cats this is all par for
the course in an rgg studio game but the
sheer breadth of diversions is still
staggering especially when so much of
them are genuinely enjoyable and this
love of distractions bleeds into lost
judgment's main narrative too yagami and
his best friend slash business partner
masaharu kaito get a call from their old
pals fumia sugira and makototsukumo
about some work in yokohama the case
which revolves around bullying
allegations at a local high school
sounds delicate but easy enough for a
seasoned pro but it gradually expands
into an intricate web that focuses on
the frailties of the justice system and
how law and order can be so easily
manipulated heavy themes such as
bullying suicide and sexual battery are
handled with a death touch required of
such topics and it even does an
excellent job of making you feel empathy
for characters that have committed
heinous acts by shrouding everything in
grey
[Music]
[Music]
moments of levity between the core cast
of friends ensure that it's not always
completely bleak although kaito takes
more of a back seat this time around
leaving yagami to carry most of the
emotional load fortunately he's still an
endearing and immediately likable
protagonist with a strict set of morals
and a steely sense of determination
that's only offset by his quick wit he
doesn't need to wrestle with as many
demons as he did in the first game and
his character development is
surprisingly light but yagami is no less
delightful to be around
lost judgment is heartfelt and
sentimental at times too even if these
moments can be a tad melodramatic but
that's to be expected if there are any
failings with the story it's that the
script can be unnecessarily verbose at
times constantly regurgitating
information you're already well aware of
aside from this however the core mystery
is frequently gripping with plenty of
unsuspecting twists and turns a devious
villain and intense moments that
guarantee you'll be perched on the edge
of your seat for the long run the high
school setting goes a long way towards
differentiating judgment from the other
rgg studio games as well the main
through line eventually leaves the score
behind but that doesn't mean you have to
in order to stay at school and continue
his investigation yagami becomes an
outside advisor for the school's mystery
club students in this extracurricular
clique usually sit around reading
sherlock holmes stories and other
mystery novels but with the argument
involved they set their sights a lot
higher it doesn't take long before
you're infiltrating various student
groups in order to unveil information
about a nefarious figure known as the
professor this elaborate side case
doesn't have anything to do with the
main story but with the setting and
characters often overlapping it all
feels interconnected and cohesive no
matter how disparate both cases are from
each other you start by helping students
perfect their craft in the dance club
which features a rhythm minigame and a
pop and locking journey to the nationals
[Music]
after this there's a robotics club where
you help engineer a fleet of robotics
and compete in competition for territory
control there's an entirely new combat
style for your fights in the boxing gym
that also comes complete with its own
separate upgrade tree and a plethora of
opponents for you to jab and hook into
submission you can also give tony hawk a
run for his money by getting involved in
a power struggle between two rival
skateboarding crews aside from adding a
veritable bucket load of variety most of
these school cases are surprisingly
comprehensive it's easy to suck up hours
of fine-tuning your robot or barreling
through the competition in the esports
club and each one features an engaging
conspiracy for you to uncover that feeds
into the overarching narrative and this
is on top of the usual slew of absurd
side missions rgg studios excels at
unfortunately yagami's investigative
repertoire is mostly unchanged from the
first game tailing missions are
mercifully less frequent this time
around and those that do exist are
slightly shorter which does alleviate
some of the arduousness there are still
plenty of on-rails chase sequences
though which are as monotonous and stale
as before occasionally you'll need to
search scenes for clues but this process
is little more than an ostentatious
pixel hunt and there are no fail states
involved when you have to present
evidence or engage in lines of
questioning so these moments lack any
real player agency parkour is a new
addition that sees you scaling pipes and
leaping across gaps to reach places
yagami isn't supposed to be there are
also a few instances of rudimentary
stealth but these sections are so
stiflingly linear that it essentially
holds your hand to the point where
you're barely even playing you're still
here to accompany yagami rather than
deduce anything yourself that doesn't
mean there aren't plenty of
opportunities to kick people's teeth in
however yagami is still adept at his own
curious brand of kung fu with both the
crane and tiger styles returning from
the first game snake style is a new
addition that specializes in disarming
enemies and countering attacks
all three styles are ostensibly designed
for specific situations crane excels at
crowd control while tiger is used to
deal heavy damage to a single target but
this isn't a strict rule and mostly
comes down to personal preference and
how much you want to shake things up
combat is as hard hitting and as
satisfying as ever particularly once you
throw in some devastating ex moves and
it also feels surprisingly fresh off the
back of yakuza like a dragon's shift to
turn based combat
lost judgement improves on its
predecessor by cutting down on some of
the more tedious elements of his design
rather than outright changing the
mechanics to make the investigative side
of the equation more engaging in this
sense it's disappointing that it doesn't
lead into what makes judgment unique
compared to the yakuza series and
instead remains at its best when
sticking close to those origins the
story is compelling with an endearing
cast of characters the sheer amount of
stuff to do is astounding and there's
still an inherent joy that comes from
pummeling the city's delinquents into
the ground but it's hard not to feel
disappointed that you still feel like a
passenger when it breaks away from the
yakuza mold if this is indeed our last
time with yagami and ko then it's one to
cherish but there'll always be that
nagging feeling that this was a missed
opportunity to do something truly
special
[Music]
you